>>presenter: So, David, for many years, was
a senior editor for Internet technology at
Fortune Magazine and he did a number of cover
stories on Internet giants and tech giants,
like Microsoft and IBM and Intel. And David's
latest project is an inside look, with the
support of Facebook's executives, at Facebook
and it's something that I'm sure you're all
familiar with.
Facebook, as we know, started in Mark Zuckerberg's
dorm room and in the last six years has really
skyrocketed to a site that has over five hundred
million members worldwide. So, David has written
a book that gives us an inside look at not
only Facebook and the evolution of that company,
but how the concept of connecting people is
really changing the world. So, without further
ado, please welcome David Kirkpatrick. Thank
you.
[applause]
>>David: I also wrote one of the very first
pieces about your company in October of 1999,
which resulted when Larry and Sergey were
on a road trip without any PR person at all.
They sat down with me in a conference room
and was telling what this thing is and it
was one of the very first pieces that kinda
put the stake in the ground that what Google
was doing was significantly different and
extremely youthful. So, yeah, I've been writing
about tech for a long time and--
[clears throat]
a lot of people, if you ask, "Why did I want
to write a book about Facebook?" And--
[clears throat]
it really rose from all the history I had
of writing about Google and Microsoft and,
and other companies that are closely related.
And, and recognizing at moderately early point,
that Facebook was s-, s-, unusual, first of
all. Just plain unusual.
And I still think Facebook is extremely unusual
in a number of respects, many, several of
which are not fully enough understood, although
I hit on them pretty hard in my book. So,
its part of the reason, I think, I wrote the
book was to try to emphasize that Facebook
is a truly unusual company. I would say that
also applies to Google, obviously. But there,
there are many things about Facebook that
even Google doesn't exactly echo, or Facebook
doesn't echo Google, since Google was the
predecessor.
And we can talk about those maybe more in
the Q&A; although I'm sure I'll hit on some
of them as I go through this. But, so, in
addition, so Facebook, when I first started
looking at it in the summer of 2006, was pretty
much stereotyped by me and by everyone as,
more or less, a plaything for kids. And I
thought of it that way, too. And kids being
in college students, by that point they were
also being used a lot in high schools and
I honestly hadn't given in that much thought,
even though there was some minor awareness
in the back of my mind that it had kind of
been coming on moderately strong.
I'm based in New York, so I think if I had
been out here, I might have been slightly
more aware of it at that point. Anyway, so
a PR person for Facebook called me in August
of '06 and said did I want to meet Mark Zuckerberg?
And I said, "Yes, of course, why not?" I mean,
I knew he was interesting. I knew something,
you know I had met with a lot of CEOs of tech
companies at that time and throughout the
time of my work at Fortune, and I don't work
at Fortune anymore, by the way.
So, I, I joined him for lunch at an Italian
restaurant in Midtown on, I think it was September
6th, 2006. And that date is somewhat significant,
if that's the correct date, but whatever day
it was, it was significant because it was
at the very height of the newsfeed controversy.
And--
[audience member clears throat]
it had only been a few days earlier that the
newsfeed had launched and those of you who
are students of Facebook will recall that,
you, you may think they've had a privacy controversy
recently, but in September of 2006, ten percent
of all their members were actively protesting
the change they had just introduced.
Now, they only had nine million members, but
close to a million of them were actively protesting
the introduction of the newsfeed. Now that,
in retrospect, seems kind of odd, considering
that anyone who uses Facebook knows that the
newsfeed is kind of its central feature without
which it would, more or less, feel pretty
useless.
However, when it was introduced, the members
did not like it and even all those, there
was hardly anybody to be found who liked it
in its first days. So, there was this huge
protest underway--
[clears throat]
have lunch with Zuckerberg, he walks into
the restaurant, he'd been up most of the night
before writing his famous letter of apology
to his members, in which he was announcing
that they were making changes and adding some
relatively minor, but, by the way, privacy
tweaks that allowed you to have a little more
control of how the newsfeed data flowed inside
Facebook.
But what was really amazing to me, particularly
in retrospect, once I sort of digested what,
what had happened, was that he didn't even
really want to talk about the controversy.
He treated it as, more or less, a minor matter.
He wasn't focused on it in our meeting whatsoever.
He was focused entirely on the long term view;
the big picture significance of the service
that he was creating. How it was here for
the duration, how it was about to launch only
a few weeks after that for all adults of any,
people of any age over 13, so that hadn't
quite happened. It was still just for students
of high schools and colleges at the time when
I met him, but they did what they called "open
registration" in, about three weeks later.
They did delay it a few weeks because of all
the controversy over the newsfeed, but especially
in retrospect, after I was thinking about
the meeting and, and paid more attention to
what was happening in the controversy, I,--
I. just-- in the days after I, I had lunch
with him, I, it, it, it struck me very strongly
that it was extraordinary that he was not
feeling the slightest bit burdened by this,
this whole problem.
And as time passed that seemed even more extraordinary
and, and looking back I think it's very indicative
of the way Mark Zuckerberg thinks. And I also
really felt that he was a leader and a and
a thinker and a big picture visionary of a
sort that really doesn't come along very often
in the technology industry. And I, I do have
the privilege; somebody can move my coat and
somebody can sit there, by the way, if you
wanna fit more people in.
But I, I knew Bill Gates pretty well. I talked
to Larry and Sergey, I mean, I knew the people
who did this kinda stuff and he seemed to
me like one of th-, the greats of the order
of magnitude of those people, you know? And
it was, really, --the scope of the vision,
the v-, --big picture way of thinking and
the ambition. Now, at that time, you couldn't
say that he had executed on it to a superbly
impressive extent at this point, you'd have
to give him credit for that, I think'd say.
And he still, more or less, thinks primarily
about the long term and the big picture, by
the way, which is kind of interesting and
in fact, I think if you were to really get
inside his head, wh-, which I have done a
tiny bit in recent weeks about what just has
happened with the changes they announced at
f8 a; and the intr-, the reaction that the
world had; and the, the privacy advocates
had; and Chuck Schumer and, and Al Franken
and the other Senators who wrote letters to
Facebook had,. dDespite all that, in his head
it's a minor perturbation in a much bigger,
long term thing, you know? Yes, he took a
few steps back.
Five steps forward, half a step back is kinda
the way I think about the way he operates
in these situations. He doesn't really surrender
very much and he didn't really surrender very
much recently, just as he didn't in the newsfeed
controversy. I mean, what he did was he basically
changed and made a significant percentage
of the data that had been forcibly exposed
on Facebook opt in,. nNo, no, he gave you
an opt out. That's what he did, which wasn't
even available for things like hiding your
friends list, right?
But, in reality, the number of people who
were gonna use, take that option and use the
opt out is infinitesimal in the scale of the
500 million users of Facebook that they have
roughly at the moment. Growing a million a
day, thereabouts, I mean, people at Google
probably aren't as in need of being told some
of the basics about Facebook, as most of the
audiences I speak to, but we can talk about
the numbers and all that stuff if you want.
I mean, Facebook's growth is extraordinary.
Facebook's social penetration in countries
around the world is extraordinary. It is predominantly
not an American service, just in case you
hadn't focused in on that, even though there's
130 million Americans on Facebook. There are
500 million. And in countries like UK, Canada,
little countries like Iceland, big countries
like Turkey and Indonesia.
The percentage of users, if you put people
who are on the Internet, is much higher than
it is in the United States. Like, in the UK
and Canada, the percentage of the total population
that's on Facebook is substantially higher
than in the United States; in the --40 per-,
mid for-, mid to low, --low to mid 40s of
a percent of a total population of everybody
from age zero to dead, whereas the United
States, it's only, only, like 34, 35 percent,
something like that, of all people.
But then, in a country like Indonesia, only
maybe ten percent, fifteen percent of the
population is even on the Internet. Almost
all of them are on Facebook and that's more
or less true in an awful lot of countries
that many Americans, I mean, don't, don't
think much, or nearly enough, about. And Turkey
is a good example. I think Tur-, --I think
now, --Indonesia might have just become Facebook's
third largest country after the US and the
UK. It was formerly Turkey, so those countries
are especially interesting. I don't even know
exactly why it's those countries that have
picked up so much, but I will say that those
are the kinds of countries that Facebook is
most targeting right now for its growth, which
is the whole world, the most populist countries,
regardless of where they are.
And actually my, my very lengthy outline of
my talk here has global down at the bottom,
--but since I'm talking about that, --one
of the things that is interesting to think
about with Facebook is, now if you look at
what is Mark Zuckerberg's personal goal for
his service and what is the strategic direction
that Facebook, itself, considers itself to
be pursuing.
One aspect of it is a word that they do actually
use, which is "ubiquity." And, it's a somewhat
hubristic notion for most companies, although
probably not for yours,. bBut there are not
too many companies that it wouldn't be hubristic
even to talk about such a thing, but at Facebook
it is certainly not, considering that in six
years they've already gotten about a third
of all the people in the world who are on
the Internet to use this thing actively.
But the vision is to basically provide, and
so let me just talk about the vision and then
I'll get back to a, a global point. Facebook's
strategy is long term, not really to get the
whole world using Facebook, but to transform
itself into infrastructure. So that all the
changes that they announced at the recent
FAf8 Conference in which their platform was,
effectively, for the first time, very aggressively
extended to s-, the, to be usable by sites
and, and, and, --and, --and partners outside
of Facebook's own confines. That was very
strongly indicative of the company's long
term strategic direction.
Their goal, I mean, fir--, I don't think they
believe, --I don't think Mark Zuckerberg believes
that he can really win, or even really survive,
by competing with all of the competitors that
are inevitably gonna target him over time
as his company gets such massive footprint
in scale in terms of usage. Like, the company
they think about a lot right now, for example,
is Foursquare, you know?
This kinda thing scares them because little
companies with really good ideas that do related
things can come on extremely quickly and get
a lot of enthusiasm really fast and in the
long run, --the sort of legacy problem, --the
thing that you could argue is, has been in
the process of killing Microsoft for ten years,
is gonna, --if Facebook just stays facebook.com,
--it will kill it at some point. That's, --to
me, --a given. However, and I think that's
a given to them, too, and to Mark in particular.
However, they have a unique opportunity--
[clears throat]
because of their scale and because of the
nature of what they do and because of the
fact that they have uniquely convinced people
to make Facebook into an identity repository
for personal data and a repository for connectivity
for the "social graph," as they call it, the
network of relationships among your friends;
the friends of any member of Facebook.
That is their core asset;. tThe fact that
they have convinced you to put your data in
there and to articulate your friend relationships.
And so,, the strategy is to turn the whole
thing into infrastructure, to go beneath the
surface of the Internet, you know?
And if there's any other commercial company
that's ever succeeded at anything like that,
it is your own, although, Google still operates
kind of above the surface of the Internet
with a website, but in reality, the nature
of its use is almost, arguably, infrastructural
just because of the overwhelming ubiquity
practically of people who do use the service.
But I don't think, I don't know whether Google
has ever actually thought of it quite this
way and I don't think it's quite as appropriate,
but in, in Facebook's case, they believe that
if they can effectively extend their platform
for the usage of anyone, my website, your
personal website, cocacola.com, usgov, dot
gov, whatever,. any, a Any entity, then they
have a unique set of assets that are truly
valuable employed anywhere on the Internet
in order to bring your friend relationships
with you and turn any experience social.
And it, to really extend that to the ultimate
extent, if you believe, --as I do, --you know,
it's ar-, it's obvious to probably most of
you, the Internet is becoming a mobile device
phenomenon. The Internet is increasingly going
to be with us everywhere. I mean, I used Google
Maps like three times on my way here.
And, and that's, that's, , I actually probably
use Google more on this device now than on
my laptop, --which is my other computer, --which
now that I have an iPad and this and it, I
mean, I actually really do use the laptop
less. The mobile things, alright, this is
not, —this is not surprising to you, but
anyways. So, but if you think of it that way
and you take, take these devices a few more
steps in their logical evolutionary direction,
I haven't stood in line for the iPhone4 yet,
but I will. And then I'll get the smaller
one and the faster one and the one that you
guys do with HTC or whatever, and the world
will, I believe.
So, if that's true then, basically, this thing
Facebook wants to do, which is to be a, a
tool that partners with you wherever you go
on the Internet, it's gonna be everywhere
you go. It's gonna be your whole life, potentially.
That's the goal. I mean, I'm sure that's the
goal, Google thinks about, too, and you're
doing a pretty good job of it. But Facebook,
--Facebook would like to be a, --a tool that
you employ regardless of what you're doing.
Period.
And, --I know, I, some, on--one way I try
to explain that in terms of, "What would that
mean?" you should be able to and you should
will and Google's working on aspects of this,
too, just walk down the street, turn your
device on or just glance at your device, which
will probably always be on and learn whether
there's anything in the vicinity that was
of interest to your friends. Not to mention
any of your friends that might be in the vicinity.
If you choose to have that kind of information
given to you, it will be trivially easy to
provide that to you in the architecture that
we're building in the Internet and that Facebook
is a key, critical component of, in my opinion.
And because they are the ones who have those
friend connections.
OKOk, so, that's the goal. That's the dr-,--
and, --and so they don't think they can compete
as a website. And their str-, , their corporate
strategy is to diminish their role as facebook.com
website and to transit their role to the far
more defensible, strategic position of being
infrastructure, which nobody but them could
do currently. And therefore, they wannat to
get, --as quickly as possible, --to that place
where they are, where they are underneath
the surface doing a unique set of functions
that no one else could tr-, mimic.
[beeping noise]
And in a minute, if I don't f-, f-, remember,
remind me to talk about the policy and governmental
implications of that because I find them quite
interesting. aAnd there's not a slam dunk
that they're gonna get from here to there.
However, OKok, going back to the global point,
if their goal is global ubiquity, there is
one fundamental problem I think. I think it's
interesting to think about probably especially
for you here at Google, that they have to
solve, and that is China. bBecause China is
where the world's largest mass of Internet
users reside. aAnd if Facebook seeks to be
in-, infrastructure for the Internet, you
can't succeed at that if the largest group
of Internet users aren't using you.
And so, Mark even said at a speech he gave
this week, I think he said Russia, China,
Japan, and one other country, --I forget which
one it was, --are their primary strategic
growth targets right now and basically, their
primary strategic targets. But it's interesting
that even he says that, considering Facebook
doesn't even operate at all in China right
now. It's turned off by the government. Or,
no, it isn't turned off by the government,
well, maybe it is, but Facebook hasn't even
really tried.
At one point maybe they had, I don't know,
75 thousand, 100 thousand users in China.
Not millions, I don't believe. Now, only people
that use Facebook in China are government
employees and maybe 20 thousand of them or
30 thousand, but Facebook's effectively not
used in China. Their, their dilemma here is
not at all dissimilar to yours, which is it's
a company committed to the free flow of information.
How do you operate in a country that is not
committed to the free flow of information?
That is the largest company in the world on
the Internet and I wish you luck in resolving
that problem and to them, too. But I will
just tell you that's something they're thinking
about right really hard at Facebook. So, lemme
see how much time I've already eaten up, but
I wanna wrap it fairly soon. But, just let
me quickly say what I think Facebook does
that makes it different. I see it as a viral
communications tool that, in some ways, can
be defined as the next phase of communication
beyond email.
That's an extreme statement in some peoples
opinion, but I believe there's something fundamentally
different about the way that Facebook's communications
architecture was designed, which allows you
to, --essentially, I mean, --basically they
turned people into RSS feeds kind of, to think
of it technically. And, and that was new.
That was very, very new and it was putting
out the newsfeed that enabled them to do that.
And, and, another aside, I'm a big aside guy.
I'm not a very linear thinker, but it's an
irony.
All the comparisons between Twitter and Facebook
and how Facebook took so much from Twitter
a couple years ago; a year and a half, two
years ago. And they more or less tried to,
to co-opt their business by building, which
they failed to do, --by the way, --but they
certainly took the features and put them in
Facebook.
But in reality, Twitter borrowed enormously
from Facebook in its fundamental design from
day one because Facebook pioneered this notion
of a feed about people, which Twitter is also
built around. That was a huge innovation that
Facebook, Zuckerberg, pioneered in, in September
of 2006, when I met him.
So, but what it does, --if I, the way I look
at it is, --all communication between people
pretty much, certainly ordinary people, before
Facebook came along was based, were based
around an outbound effort to communicate.
So, I would send a letter to you, a telegram,
make a phone call, make an outbound effort
to communicate. Facebook doesn't require that.
Facebook sets up a scenario where people subscribe
to one another and all you do as a user is
act. You just say, "I'm going to the bathroom,"
or one of these banal things that people ridicule
Facebook for containing. oOr you say, "I've
joined the group protesting the, the MousaviMusabi
had the election stolen from him or whatever
in Iran." But you just do something and then
that is transmitted algorithmically and by
the software to whoever has subscribed to
you by saying they're your friend.
And I, I call that, in a certain sense, automating
communication in a way that it has never been
automated before. And I, I assert in the book
and, and people in here know a lot more than
I do about certain things, but I say it's
the fir-, --it's to me, --the introduction
of automation to communication for the first
time. And, and interestingly, I don't think
Zuckerberg thinks of it that way.
He doesn't actually think of Facebook as communication,
which is interesting, but that's a more complicated
conversation. I don't even fully understand
why. But, sSo Facebook has this, this automated
way of, of disseminating information about
people, which I think is, was essentially,
fundamentally new and again, required the
newsfeed.
And it, it takes advantage of this extraordinary
virality that occurs because of the connectivity
that, of, the, the, that they set up in the
social graph, so that information, when it
is welcomed by a group, can spread with extraordinary
rapidity between communities of, throughout
communities. And you see that in something
like the, the role that Facebook played in
the election of Barack Obama.
It was very, very reinforcing to learn that
your friends had joined a group supporting
him, therefore it was easy for you to join
a group supporting him and the fact that you
did was conveyed automatically to your friends
and then that's a very rapid process of, based
on network effects and all that, that Facebook
was very-- u-, I, not uniquely, --but very
powerfully, in its part of its system enables.
And the other thing about Facebook that, that,
here's a little thing, and there's not time
to talk about everything in any individual
talk, but if you ask, "Why did Facebook succeed
when MySpace, Friendster, others failed?"
There's a number of reasons. The biggest,
single reason is that Facebook was based on
genuine identity from the beginning.
So, it was your real name and your real friend
relationships, in--, in, more or less--, your
real social graph. Facebook can be gamed,
I mean, I was on this Ronn Owens radio show
yesterday and the engineer was, the producer
was telling me how his wife set up a Facebook
page for their dog, which has seven hundred
friends.
[laughter]
And that does happen. And also, people create
Face-, fake personas to play Farmville and
other games, or Mafia Wars more than Farmville,
but so, there's a lot of fake identities in
Facebook, but that's still not primarily what
its used for and its pretty good at pushing
its users towards being authentic and, and
nothing that preceded it ever did that well.
Friendster tried and totally failed. MySpace
didn't even try.
But a lot of the things that Facebook makes
possible, the thing I was talking about when
you're walking down the street, you couldn't
do that if you didn't have genuine identity
and genuine friend relations. It would be
pointless. I mean, I don't care what some
handle who I don't even know the person behind,
liked about the store I'm walking by or didn't
want to drink the water at this drinking fountain
and then that kind of thing is what I think
you're gonna be able to know.
But, so I'm going quickly, but I feel like
you guys can probably handle that. So, another,
so the book is called, "The Facebook Effect."
It is the inside story. It's very much a history
of the company and it's a really fun business
book to read. Aand it, it's funny because
it's a real business book and I really think,
and a lot of people tell me, it's really fun
to read because the anecdotes that emerge
from the story of a company founded by a bunch
of 19 year olds are pretty frickinfreaking'
amazing.
I mean, it's just, especially the role of
Sean Parker, who was one of the great, the
fou-, great,great figures in Facebook's history,
who was truly an iconoclast great figures
in Facebook's history, who was truly an iconoclast
and, and brought his iconoclastic sensibility
to Facebook and it's still very, very much
manifest in the product designed today. And
he's the one that allowed Mark to acquire,
by the way, the, the ability, this absolute
control he has, where he controls three out
of five board seats and nothing can be done.
At your company, there's a lot of power rested
in the c-, founders, but I don't know of any
big company where there's one guy who absolutely
cannot be removed, cannot be deposed, three
out of five board seats, no matter what, Zuckerberg
will be there if he wants to be there. He
will squash anything he does not want to see
happen. That's it. Period.
And Sean Parker, architect of that in the
very early days. And anyway, so, back to the
effect. When I call it the Facebook effect,
even though it's a history, what I really
am trying to imply is that Facebook has this
very interesting range of effects in the world,
which are in politics, government, media,
marketing, identity, personal relations, etc.
And the politics is one that I find particularly
interesting, and it happens that Mark Zuckerberg
is also quite obsessed with., Aand the book
begins in a way that I think a lot of people
find surprising. It's not a Facebook scenario.
It begins in the bedroom of a 32 year old
computer programmer, in the middle of the
night in Barranquilla, Columbia, in January
2008, who was just fed up with the FARC guerrillaguerilla
movement, killing and kidnapping his countrymen
over the previous decades. Aand there was
a little, a recent story of really abusing
a small child that, and he's a very sensitive
kid, he's a real sensitive soul, this guy,
Oscar Morales. And, and he just got fed up
and he's a computer guy, so he knew how to
make a Facebook page and do some good graphics
and he did that at 3 AM, went to bed, and
he sent an invitation to all his friends to
join the group. And in the morning, he had,
I think, 1200 members of the group when he
woke up. And he only had 150 friends or something
like that, so that got his attention and then
he went to the p-, beach that day and came
home and there were, I don't know, I forget
the number, 4000 friends or something like
that. And, and I love this quote, he says,
"I decided to stop going to the gym and just
focus on." and a month to the day, after that,
he created it.
There was a, a demonstration on the streets
of Columbia of ten million people, with a
simple message. "FARC: Stop killing, stop
kidnapping, no more lies." And it was very
simple and it, it really just was the message
that was poised to be received by the country
at that time and it was Facebook that enabled
it to happen. So, that kind of thing happens
in a lot of places. I think the actual impact
of it is still hard to say at the moment,
but it is the feeling of members of Facebook
that if they're upset about anything, whether
its political or nonpolitical, Facebook is
a very good place to say that. aAnd, and the
message can spread very rapidly. aAnd that
has a lot of political implications. The effects
in marketing, etc., are things could talk
about cause they're very big., bBut I've sort
of already talked about the future. Zucker-,
I mean I think I've kind of hit on the main
points that I, I, I like to, to, to, to highlight
and I'd love to hear your comments and questions,
so let's go right to a dialogue. I think you
have to go over there to the mic in order
to talk in any form because--
[audience chatter]
there's people from at like three or four
other locations that are watching this.
[clears throat]
>>memberman in audiencemale #1: Hey, there.
So, I work in the PR department and full disclosure
I answer a lot of questions about Facebook
all the time. One thing that kinda bothers
me about it, and you touched on this earlier,
is that if Facebook, strategically, wants
to be the social plumbing under everything--
>>David: OKOk, that's a good way to put it,
yeah.
>>membermaleman in audience #1: they wanna
own that social--
>>David: Social plumbing, I like that, yeah.
>>membermaleman in audience #1: every time
you wanna reference that, you ping their API,
you get it back--
>>David: Uh-huh.
>>membermaleman in audience #1: but the problem
with that is, is they're owning something
that belongs to me, right? I own my address
book, I know the little black book, and that's
something that I carry with me.
>>David: Right.
>>membermaleman in audience #1: If I wanna
export my Gmail contacts--
>>David: Mm-hmm.
>>membermaleman in audience #1: I can do that,
but with Facebook, it's somehow telling me
that I don't own the set of relationships
between me and other people.
>>David: Yeah.
>>membermaleman in audience #1: And so there
seems to be some kind of tension between the
data that I own about myself and their strategic
vision.
>>David: Well, technically speaking, during
the Terms of Service controversy of a year
or so ago, they altered that and they don't
technically claim to own your data anymore,
although they did before that. They, they
do in practical fact, control your data.
And they don't let you export it nearly so
easily as most other services do. I wouldn't
be surprised if begin to allow that going
forward, just because of the many policy implications
and legal implications of their ambition.
that, I think, they're gonna have to move
in a number of respects, toward a more opt-in
architecture rather than the opt-out architecture,
which is really one of the reasons they've
had so much difficulty on the privacy front.
So, I think it's a legitimate point and the
thing is it's, it's "user beware" and that's
the thing you have, I mean, it's just on practical
terms, the members on Facebook don't pay anything,
they like using it and they put that stuff
in there because they get benefits from it.
If that stopped being the case, they would
remove their data and Facebook's great challenge
is to make sure they continue to feel that
trade-off is worth it.
And so far there's no question they've succeeded
at that., b But from a intellectual point
of view, you're point is totally justified
and I think that that kind of thing is just
starting to sink in on the world. Aand how
the world responds and how Facebook responds
to the world in that regard is very important.
And, so that's, that's all I'd say about that.
B, but I wanna say one other thing before
I go to the next question about Google because
I meant to do that in, in my talk.
Facebook and Google's relationship and connectivity
and, and, and the comparison between the two
is really, really fascinating. And has anybody
here actually read my book already, by the
way? Well, I think you have a great opportunity
in the future. Anyway--
[laughter]
you read it, oh good. Well, you know that
the last chapter is a lot about Google, right?
And, and it, it, just quickly, I think it's
worth mentioning and I'm sure some of you
will have reactions to some of this, but Facebook
is a problem for Google in a number of respects.
Three primarily, primary respects, in my opinion.
I mean, and it, if I were you, I would say
it's probably your single biggest problem
in terms of competitively. And which is why
I think it's not wrong that so many people
are sitting in this room trying to get to
the floor because if you if , if, if the leaders
of Google and the people who are making policy
decisions about Google and, and where Google's
going,. I If you don't focus on what Facebook
is doing to alter the landscape in which you
operate, you're naive. And you're not naive
at all in this company.
So, here's the three ways that I think Facebook
is a problem for Google. I think the number
one way is that Google's corporate mandate
and mantra is to search all the worlds' information.
And Facebook is aggregating the largest quantity
of digital information that anybody is aggregating
at the moment, I believe., cCertainly of any
commercial company, and the vast majority
of it is not visible to you.
Therefore, if you're trying to search everything
on the Internet, it's not a good thing that
the biggest growing piece of the Internet
data universe is invisible to your crawling
tools. There's an irony in that, by the way,
which is that almost everything Mark Zuckerberg
has been doing recently that he's getting
in trouble for would help you with that problem
because he wants everyone to use the everyone
privacy setting.
And this the really, wait, Mark Zuckerberg
is not an easy person to, he's not, he's not
easy to intuitively understand cause he's
very principled, very intellectual and not
a business minded person by instinct. He is
trying to change the world more than he's
trying to make money and that is always a
controversial statement, but that is the case
about him. I think, at least for most of the
history of Google, that same thing was true
about Larry and Sergey and probably to a larger
degree is still true.
I mean, Google's so much more mature of a
company that's it's much harder to maintain
that, that attitude than it is for Mark at
Facebook, but anyway, so Marks trying to make
everyone make all their information visible,
which if that succeeded then Facebook wouldn't
have that problem. But at the moment, most
users of Facebook are still hiding a lot of
their data. I don't even know the percentage.
A very rapidly growing percentage of data
inside Facebook is searchable by anyone, so
that's good.
The second thing is that Facebook is the most
targetable medium in history because it is
full of user identified data. The users volunteer
data about themselves, which is very different
from the way DoubleClick and other systems
identify people's interests and behavior,
wh-, wh-, what I call, what is logically called
inferential reasoning.
You observe people and figure out what they
probably are, want and who they probably are.,
bBut it's far better to have them just tell
you and in Facebook's case, they do.
Therefore, to the degree Google's in the advertising
business, which of course it is, Facebook's
a problem because if that kind of advertising
works well, --which there are some signs that
its beginning to work better and better in
their universe--, you've gotta get even better
at the inferential stuff or else you've gotta
get access to volunteered data.
And then the third piece, which is closely
related to the second one, is that Google's
business, in large part through AdSense, is
a ad, ad distribution business and ad network
business. Aand Facebook has not gone into
that business yet. But if you dovetail this
commercial stuff with what I said before about
their strategic goal of becoming infrastructure,
and the Facebook connect system and the like
button and all that stuff and just imagine
what happens when, not if, but, in my opinion
when, they begin to distribute advertising
using that same infrastructure with all of
the user reported data behind it, so then
they begin to compete with AdSense on any
website by telling the website, "We know who
that person is and what they say they're interested
in." Not what we've guessed and then they,
they depri-, on you, they can split the revenue
in a lot of different ways with that partner
site and target people with extraordinary
accuracy. Aand so those are three big challenges
for Google that I just didn't wanna get out
of here without saying clearly, so go ahead.
>>membermaleman in audience #2: Hello. So,
apo-, I guess in advance I'll apologize for
this question and I totally understand if
you don't really wanna talk about it from
a personal or a legal kinda point of view,
but what do you think, personally, is wrong
with Facebook? Whether it's from a technical
or a political or just kind of an overall
like, phil-, philosophical point of view.
>>David: Well, there's plenty of things that
are wrong with the way it's moving and with
the decisions it's making. I mean, I am, as
you could probably tell, something of an enthusiast
about its significance. Aand because I've
been an enthusiast or a believer in its significance
for a long time, I, I sometimes sound like
I'm a cheerleader, is a word that Michael
Errington used to me in private, which he
did not use in his very two-sided review of
my book the other day, although he did say
you should read it, by the way, in case you
didn't notice that.
But, I mean, I think Facebook has not wrestled
with the fundamental question of how they
can function as a commercial enterprise? I
mean, basically, their ambition is highly
questionable from a policy point of view.
Why should a company own identity infrastructure?
That, in history of mankind to the degree
such things existed, that has been a governmental
function.
Now, the argument that you could rebut that
with, and this is why, I mean, I don't think
Facebook is evil or not evil. I think there's,
things are nuanced in my mind, I'm a journalist
and I'm not a, I'm also, I've never been a,
I'm not really a classic blogger type who
makes these extreme statements just to see
what people think. I really look at the world
in a fairly nuanced way. I don't think Google
is evil or not evil, either. But, although
I did write a piece once saying Google is
not evil. But anyway,--
[laughter]
so, the problem with the, with the problem,
if you call that a problem is that Facebook
really is enabling people to do new things
that probably could not be done if they hadn't
emerged and people like that. That's why they
have a million new users a day coming in there
and they have 500 million active users.
I mean, arguably, they're providing something
that people like. And it's impossible to imagine
that governments could ever have invented
it. I mean, governments are clueless about
this stuff. So, you could legitimately ask,
maybe should Facebook in some future scenario
possibly be regulated by the ITU or, I don't
think so, necessarily, but believe me, the
ITU is gonna start wondering in a few years
if they don't start wondering soon, that someone
at Facebook, who I was talking to yesterday,
said, "You know if you keep talking like this
the government officials might start regulating
us sooner rather than later." I said, "Well,
you know, that's the breaks." But I think
this regulation thing is real and you're encountering
it. Look at the 40 countries, however many
countries, how many countries are now suing
you because of the, the street view cameras?
I don't know.
[man speaking in background]
Thirty states, fifteen countries, thank you.
[laughter]
So, you're encountering it already, right?
And, and nobody's gonna argue Google's not
a good thing for the average user, but there's,
these, these nuanced situations when you acquire
these incredibly complex, complexedambitious,
successful systems that are deployed in the
hundreds of millions, bring about tons of
issues., ambitious, successful systems that
are deployed in the hundreds of millions,
bring about tons of issues. I think, I don't
think of wrong or right, but I'll tell you
a huge challenge that I think Facebook faces,
which is Mark Zuckerberg's personality.
And I think this company faced the same challenge
and, and they solved it by hiring Eric Schmidt.
Mark is a geek, computer scientist type person
and that's the way he sees the world, through
the product and engineering lens. And he's
basically inclined to solve every product,
problem by redesigning the product. And that's
a fine thing and it's worked pretty well.,
Bbut if you watched his DSpeech or you've
read a lot of the commentary about him recently,
you can't deny that that's not the only thing
he has to do. He has to become an ambassador,
a policy expert, a policy articulator, a front
man, a marketer, in a way that he's probably
personally uncomfortable to be and, and maybe
not capable of being.
Although, knowing how much he's matured in
the f-, mere six years since he's run this
thing, I would not put it past him at all
that he could become that person. But he's
not that person now, which is why he totally
screwed up at D, so from Facebook's point
of view, Mark Zuckerberg's personality is
a problem.
>>membermaleman in audience #2: Thank you.
>>David: Not, not necessarily a long term
problem. It could be resolved, but right now
I think he's got to get better at something
he doesn't like to do.
>>membermaleman in audience #3: Hi. So, one
of the things I've been wondering is Facebook
doesn't seem to pick its battles very much.
It's competing with Zynga, the payment platform,
it's competing with Foursquare and Gowalla
and the location of mobile services, its competing
with Google on user attention, it's competing
with Open Web advocates about what, who owns
information. What do you think is the psychology
behind that? Why--
>>David: Well, I would say most of those competition
are inadvertent. I mean, honestly, it's not
seeking to compete in that way with any of
those players, certainly not with Google on
attention. By that logic, you'd say if you
get it successful you've made the mistaken
decision to compete with Google, I mean that's
a very, talk about hubris, I'm sorry, but
that's not a very logical point, I'm sorry.
But anyway, Facebook is just doing what it's
doing and, and in order to achieve what they
think they wanna do, which is to provide all
these services to the users based on identity
and the social graph, they, they have to go
into identity based information.
Now, it, will they buy Foursquare or build
something to compete with it? That's unknown.
I actually think they do pick their battles.
That's why they really just wanna be infrastructure.
That's what I tried to say before. They don't
really think they can win those battles the
way you described them in general, u. Unless
they become a service that you just use and
that nobody effectively can compete with.
I mean, and that's, that's a complicated and
challenging idea, but it's kind of an, you
could say that Facebook's gamble is kind of
all or nothing. Butnothing, but maybe not.
bBecause they could build this ad network
and they could still be facebook.com and they
could be around for a long time because they've
got a lot of critical mass.
When you talk about, I mean, each one of those
things is very different, also. I mean, the
Zynga issue, it's not like, this thing of
Facebook credits is really what you're asking
about and Facebook credits are, if you don't
know, Facebook'sFacebooks got this new business,
which is selling its users a credit for a
dollar and giving these partners 70 cents
and the partners are primarily game companies.
And the money is primarily used to buy virtual
goods in games and game tools.
And the thing that's two sided about that--,
even for Zynga--, is that even though Zynga
doesn't wanna give 30 percent to Facebook,
it wants those people to be spending money
inside Farmville. aAnd they're generally in
Facebook more inclined to spend their money
on Facebook than they are on Zynga because
if you buy a dollars worth of credit on Facebook,
you can use it in Zynga and you can also use
it at CrowdStar or another platform.
It's a, it's a currency that can be used across
the network and if you buy it only from Zynga
then you're stuck to use it in Zynga and that,
and, and if you think that digital currency
has a l-, future--, which I do--, I think
Facebook'sFacebooks well positioned to be
a player in that arena, so they're not making
a mistake at all to try and get in that business.
But specifically with Zynga, they had secret
negotiations, they came to a concord, Zynga's
got a lot better deal than they had before,
would be my guess.
Zynga has leverage over Facebook because it's
its largest advertiser, but at least it was
last year by all accounts. But this issue
of, I would say the most interesting part
of your question, which had a lot of pieces,
actually, was this issue of how does it relate
to its platform partners? And does it compete
with them or does it only help them? And I
think in technology platforms, generally,
there's never, it's never black or white.
I mean, Microsoft did a very, very good job
on balance, serving as a platform and creating
this incredible pro developer culture and
enabling all these applications to emerge.
You guys haven't done as much of that as I
would have expected you to do by now, by the
way, but you're doing some of it, certainly.
And Face-, any, this, there's really a devils
bargain, you could say, that a lot of companies
are faced with right now, which is, do you
build on top of the Facebook platform and
get this viral growth potential, which is
incredibly powerful, at the price that you
are effectively dependentdependant on Facebook's
future decisions?
And, and possibly at risk that they might
choose to go into your business and just render
you irrelevant overnight. And that's the kind
of thing that Foursquare and Gowalla are in
that position right now, that if Facebook
does do location based, in a way that analogous
to what those companies are doing, then they'll
probably have a hard time going forward.
[audienceaudicence member coughs]
But Facebook doesn't really want to kill them
because those two companies are built on the
Facebook platform and that's basically how
they get users. So, ecosystem management on
F-, technology platforms is a very challenging
managerial and business issue, which I find
fascinating. I've written about it a lot over
the years and I, I don't think it's black
or white., bBut its' a, it's a really good
question that's almost unanswerable. Nobody's
lined up, should I just keep talking?
[laughter]
Nobody has questions or comments? Do we get
questions or comments from the other locations
or do they just have to be mute?
[woman answers]
They're mute? But do they get, do they have
the technical ability to ask questions?
>>woman: No, not at this--
>>David: OKOk, let's see how much more time
we have.
>>woman: Five minutes.
>>David: You've been sated with Facebook information?
Did I, what did I, come on, somebody in here
must think I said something that was totally
full of shit.
[laughter]
Am I entitled to say that word? Can, could
somebody just tell me what you disagree with
about the things that I've said? Yeah. You
gotta go to the mic, though, I'm sorry.
[laughter]
You're a professional spokes guy, you're--
>>membermale4: [ ]-
>>David: I know, complain to your colleagues,
what can I say?
>>membermaleman in audience #4: Just that
you keep saying that Facebook is very unique.
You can only do things on Facebook and this
thing wouldn't have any Facebook and you give
an example in Columbia. I don't think that's
true. I think Facebook is one way to do that
thing, but it probably would have happened
some other way--
>>David: It might have.
>>membermaleman in audience #4: and it's not
that Facebook has capabilities that are hard
to replicate or technically interesting. You
can be social using a flare gun, you know?
If you have to.
>>David: Yeah.
>>membermaleman in audience #4: So, I think
you're just seeing trends in society emerging
at a time when this thing came out of the
tool people could use and--
>>David: Yeah.
>>membermaleman in audience #4: it's not gonna
be sticky cause you can't do things elsewhere.
>>David: Well, yeah, but you could also say
there was always a library so why did you
need Google? I mean, i-, i-, it's, I mean,
when things are automated and, and when digital
technology is brought to a human task and
it's faster, it often becomes fundamentally
different, in my opinion. So, you could do
social things with a flare gun, but the fact
that you can do them with digital tools that
are so much more efficient, is often-- in
my opinion--, fundamentally different.
So, we differ on that perhaps, but certainly
with Twitter you can do a lot of things that
you do in Facebook. The thing I think is so,
one of the things I think was really unique
about Facebook, or is unique about it, which
kinda, I think goes to your point, is that
Facebook draws in users to do very quotidian
things, meaning to communicate with their
friends about going to the mall. That's how
people start using it, or to connect with
high school girlfriend, to speak in my generation.
But once they're in there, these other capabilities,
Oscar Morales joined Facebook to communicate
with his high school friends, and that's a
fact, right? But then he got in Facebook and
he kind of just stumbled on the fact that
it has this ability to create a group and
that it would also, and therefore, allow him
to make a political statement.
And that is different than a lot of the other
ways it might have emerged, which probably
would have had to be a little more willful.
That would be, I do probably, books are often
written by some degree of overstatement, in
fact, I hardly imagine a book that wasn't.
So, obviously, in order to make a point, sometimes
I oversimplify and I don't deny that. But
I think in general, Facebook is different
in many of its qualities and capabilities
than anything that has preceded it, I do.
>>membermaleman in audience #5: Since you
mentioned Twitter, could youprevious comment
on the relationship between Twitter and Facebook.
>>David: Sure, I think Twitter is a hugely
important business and, and system, not so
much a business obviously, but, yet, but they're
not the same in the way they're often compared.
I mean, Twitter isn't really a social network
by the classic definitions of social networks
because you don't articulate a connection
between two people in Twitter, you subscribe
to an entity, which is tweeted. And that is
a hugely valuable thing, but it's not like
what Facebook does which primarily creates
bi-directional contact, connections. And I
don't think most of the journalists who have
written about Twitter versus Facebook fully
understood that.
So , so, the interesting thing about the Twitter
versus Facebook competition, which is, is
a real competition, is Facebook did get really
terrified of Twitter at a certain point in
time. Primarily because just how fast it was
growing at that point. And they said, "Well,
if it's growing that fast, maybe it's doing
something we should do." And they are paranoid,
and so they really did, based, first they
tried to buy it, according to all accounts.
I think you guys have thought about that a
few times. Maybe you still should. In fact,
almost everywhere I go, somebody says, "Google
should buy Twitter." Whatever that's worth,
I don't know if that's right. But then Facebook
basically did copy much of whaet's in Twitter.
But whets interesting about that to me, is
that even though in Facebook, you can do a
lot of the functions that Twitter offers,
in many ways, better than the ways you can
do them in Twitter.
Like, a Facebook page, which is much like
an, a, a, a hash tag identity in Twitter,
is actually a more functional environment
in many respects to do that kind of thing.
But what's very interesting to me is that
still the most authentic, powerful, respected,
intellectual, interesting voices, are primarily
using Twitter for that kind of one to many
messaging. And that's a problem for Facebook.
And I don't think Twitters going away. I don't
think no matter what Facebook does in any
near term scenario, Twitter is going away.
But there are a lot of things that I've heard,
Twitters growth has slowed, so it doesn't
threaten Facebook the way it used to.
And now Facebook is so much bigger than Twitter,
even relatively more than it was when they
first got paranoid about it, I think, maybe
not relatively., bBut Facebook is double,
more than double the size it was when they
first worried about Twitter, right? It was
probably, when they first worried about Twitter,
it would've been like the beginning of 2009,
8, I dunno.
And they've grown several hundred million
since then, so I think they're maybe a little
more relaxed about it, but they watch that
company very closely. And, and if I were at
Facebook, I would really be strategically
thinking very hard, "How do I get those really
credible voices, why is it that when Medvedev
came to Google, the photo of him was doing
his first tweet or whatever it was?" Was it
here that he did that? He did it on his trip
to Silicon Valley, right? Medvedev was, there
was a photograph of him in the paper tweeting
for the first time. That's a problem for Facebook.
They would've liked to see him doing a Facebook
message for the first time. So, it's a big,
really good question and a really big issue,
but not as understood as it ought to be in
my opinion.
>>presenter: Great. So, let's give David a
round of applause. Thank you so much.
[applause]
>>David: Thank you all very much.